spending your entire life in space if
there's another planet suitable for
humans it will be quite a long journey
to get there even traveling at one
percent of the speed of light it would
still take 10 000 years to go only 100
light years this means that the people
who get on an Interstellar spaceship
will not be the ones who arrive such a
ship requires everything needed for a
journey lasting thousands of years
meaning you have to take everything on
board new parts for repairs food and
even new crew to replace you when you
die hundreds of generations may live and
die knowing only a spaceship as their
home you might be okay with leaving
Earth never to return but that means
you're making the same decision for your
children and grandchildren is that
ethical
imagine if your entire purpose in life
was to just maintain the life support
systems on a spaceship so that one day
your descendants could see a new world
would you be okay with someone deciding
before you're born that you're going to
be